hi I'm Sal Khan founder of Khan Academy
and with your support I'm excited to say
that 2017 has been a really incredible
year here's just a few of the things
that we've been able to accomplish
together more than math we now cover a
wide range of academic subjects
including history science grammar and
much more going global Khan Academy is
now available in more than 190 countries
and translated into 18 languages over 60
million registered users millions of
students and teachers around the world
are using Khan Academy videos
interactive exercises and assignments
new teacher tools teachers use new Khan
Academy tools to assign practice
exercises identify gaps in learning and
tracks to new progress nearly 1 million
students took part in our back to school
challenge learn storm developing new
skills and growth mindsets while
celebrating their achievements SAT
practice research found that students
who use our official SAT practice for 20
hours see an average score increase of
115 points from the PSAT to SAT official
AP practice we've partnered with the
Advanced Placement program to provide
free official practice resources for
over 20 AP courses we're really proud of
the impact we've had so far but we're
just getting started
we have big plans for 2018 and beyond
we're going to be working on lessons
across subjects for learners around the
globe and as a non-profit we need
support from people like yourself so
please consider becoming a monthly donor
because together I think we really can
deliver on the mission of a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere
you